مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في التغطيه
للتطورات في السودان هدنه الايام الثلاثه
تبادل اليوم الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه
الاتهامات بشان خلقها حيث اندلعت اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الثقيله سمعت اصداؤها بمحيط مبنى
التلفزيون في ام درمان ياتي ذلك في الوقت
الذي تتواصل فيه عمليه الاجلاء التي تقوم
بها الدول لنقل رعاياها من السودان
[موسيقى]
يمكن اصعب لحظه لحظه التفكير في الخروج
ووسط اصوات انفجارات عنيفه وسط اصوات رصاص
قرر بانه يبعد باولاده عن اماكن النزاع
بين القوات المسلحه وبين قوات الدعم
السريع
ومش كان بيقولوا في هدنه لكن حتى الهدنه
كان في حرق واضح لها يعني الواحد يتمنى
انه الحرب ينتهي ومنه يرجع الامن والامان
شجر الجيش السوداني الخرقات العديده التي
اقترفها الدعم السريع للهدنه حسب تعبيره
الجيش قال ان مجموعات الدعم السريع تواصل
تحركاتها داخل وخارج الخرطوم برغم الهدنه
حيث رفض الجيش تحركات لارسال عسكريه متجهه
من غربيه السودان الى الخرطوم اضافه الى
محاولات مجموعات من الدعم السريع السيطره
على مصفى لتحكم بالوقود الجيش اتهم الدعم
السريع ايضا باستغلال الهدنه لانقاذ
موقفها لعمله الذي وصفه بالمتدهور عبر نشر
قناصه في الخرطوم وولايات اخرى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدينا ساتابع واياكم هذه الصور التي
ورددنا قبل قليل لوصول الطائره الخامسه
لاجلاء المدنيين والدبلوماسيين طبعا من
الخرطوم الى عمان في الاردن فلنتابع الصور
اذا
مشاهدينا وصول هذه الطائره العسكريه التي
تقل اشخاص وافراد تم نقلهم واجلائهم من
الخرطوم طبعا وصولا الى بورتسودان ومن
هناك تم اجلائهم جوا الى مطار عمان حيث
نتابع وصول هذه الطائره التي هي الطائره
الخامسه التي وصلت الى مطار عمان بضمن
عمليات الاجلاء التي تقوم بها الدول
لمواطنيها ورعاياها والدبلوماسيين
والبعثات الامميه وغيرها
اذا تابعنا واياكم مشاهدينا وصول هذه
الطائره الى عمان الى المطار الموجود هناك
المطار الدولي وهي طائره عسكريه لا نعلم
طبعا العدد الموجود على مدن هذه الطائره
ولكن هي الطائره الخامسه ضمن عمليه
الاجلاء التي اطلقتها السلطات الاردنيه
طبعا بموازات عمليات الاجلاء التي اطلقتها
الدول الاوروبيه الدول العربيه وكل
الجاليات الاجنبيه والامميه التي كانت
موجوده داخل الخرطوم قبل الاشتباكات التي
اندلعت طبعا عمليات الاجلاء كما هو معلوم
ونذكر دائما مشاهدينا تتم برا من الخرطوم
وصولا الى بورسودان ومن هناك يتم نقلهم
اما ببوارج حربيه اي بسفن واما بطائرات
عسكريه
تقلهم الى
الى المكان يعني الذي
يجب ان تذهب اليه الطائره
اذا بدات عمليه انزال الركاب
الذين تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم
اصولا الى الاردن
طبعا للتفكير ايضا المسافه التي تفصل بين
الخرطوم وفورتسودان هي حوالي 900 كيلومتر
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن حوالي الخمس عشره
ساعه او 20 ساعه حتى للوصول من هناك الى
بورتسودان ومن بورسودان طبعا البعض مكث
لايام بانتظار دورهم لاجلائهم لان الاجلاء
يتم على دفعات الدفعات الاولى او الدفعه
الاولى من الاجلاء كانت تقتصر على
الرسميين البعثات الدبلوماسيه
الدبلوماسيين الامميين ومن ثم المواطنين
طبعا واسرهم
اذا عمليه افراغ الطائره وانزال الركاب
بدات هي كما نتابع طائره حربيه
تابعه للسلطات الاردنيه لسلاح الجو
الاردني
عمليه الاجلاء هذه طبعا تتوازى مع عمليات
اجلاء اخرى ان كان عبر مطار الملك عبد
العزيز في جده الذي ايضا وصلت اليه كميات
كبيره من المواطنين ومن الطائرات ومن عفوا
اذا فلنستمع الى
تصريح لوزير الخارجيه ايمن الصفدي وزير
الخارجيه الاردني فلنستمع اليه
على ما يبدو بانه سيكون هناك تصريح فننتظر
التصريح هو طبعا باستقبال المواطنين
الاردنيين لا نعلم اذا كان هناك جنسيات
اخرى موجوده هذه الطائره ولكن هو باستقبال
من تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم الى
مطار ماركا في عمان
اذا كما نشاهد نساء واطفال
[موسيقى]
ينزلون بهذه الاثناء من الطائره العسكريه
الاردنيه
وايضا عسكريين كانوا موجودين على متن هذه
الطائره والذين هم ايضا يعني تولوا عمليه
الاجلاء التي اطلقت من بورسودان
نستمع قليلا
اذا سمحت اذا
سمحت
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع واياكم عمليه
انزال الركاب
والمواطنين الذين تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم
نساء اطفال رجال موظفين يعني ينزلون تباعا
من الطائره الحربيه
باستقبالهم وفد رسميه راسه وزير الخارجيه
الاردني ايمن الصفدي
كما ذكرت هي الطائره الخامسه التي تصل الى
الاردن ضمن عمليات الاجلاء لا ارقام حتى
الساعه عن يعني اجمالي العدد الذين تم
اجلائهم من الخرطوم الى الاردن
وايضا لا ارقام عن من تبقى هناك ومن يعني
سيتم اجراءهم ايضا بالساعات المقبله لكن
المعلن حتى الساعه بان عمليات الاجلاء
ستستمر على الاقل في الساعات المقبله وفي
الايام المقبله لكل الراغبين بالخروج من
الخرطوم
اذا عمليات الاجلاء هذه
تستكمل بموازاه الهدنه التي اعلن عنها
بالامس بعد اتصال حصل بين وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي اعطني بلينكن وطرفي النزاع هناك
طبعا الجيش السوداني برئاسه البرهان وقوات
الدعم السريعه برئاسه حميد وتم الاتفاق
على هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
لاتمام عمليات الاجلاء ان كان للمواطنين
الاجانب الموجودين هناك اتحدث عن
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين قدر عددهم
الثلاثه عشر الف مواطن نحن نتحدث عن حاملي
الجنسيه المزدوجه كان هناك تقارير عديده
اليوم حول يعني هذا العدد الكبير الموجود
داخل السودان معظمهم حاملي الجنسيات
المزدوجه وهم صادف وجودهم داخل الخرطوم
لقضاء عطله عيد الفطر ورمضان هناك مع
الاشتباكات التي ان دلعت
اذا ما زلنا بهذه الصور من مطار ماركا في
عمان
لعمليه انزال الركاب الدفعه الخامسه
للمواطنين الذين تم اجلائهم من الخرطوم
بموازاه استمرار
الاشتباكات طبعا بالرغم من الهدنه هناك
يعني خرق متواصل واشتباكات متقطعه بين
الطرفين
كما نتابع يعني عائلات امهات اطفال لنساء
رجال عائلات باكملها تصل وتنزل بهذه
الاثناء من الطائره العسكريه التابعه
للخطوط
الجويه الاردنيه
شباب
وجود رسمه عسكري
على ارض المطار لاستقبال هذه الطائره
بعدما يعني قامت السلطات الاردنيه كما
السلطات بالدول الاخرى بانشاء خليه ازمه
للتنسيق مع اطراف النزاع هناك ومع كل
المسؤولين طبعا عن عمليات الاجلاء لاتمام
عمليات الاجلاء
مع يعني كل احترام وكل معايير السلامه
وايصال المواطنين الى اراضيهم سالمين
اذا بانتظار شهووز الاتصال مع مراسل
العربيه من ارض المطار هناك ساعيد واذكر
بان عمليات اجلاء المواطنين والرعايه
الاجانب والعرب تتم منذ ايام بدات بمرحله
اولى مع الدبلوماسيه مع الامميين وتستقبل
الان بمرحله ثانيه مع المواطنين واسرهم
طبعا هي لكل من يرغب بالخروج من الخرطوم
يخرج من الخرطوم برا الى بورسودان ومن
بورسودان اما عبر البوارج الحربيه اتحدث
عن السفن واما جوا عبر الطائرات التي
سيرتها الدول ان كان الاردن كما نشاهد هنا
ان كان فرنسا ان كان بريطانيا ايطاليا
الولايات المتحده وغيره من الدول التي
ارسلت طائرات حربيه لاخ
راج مواطنيها ورعاياها طبعا من
من الخرطوم بعد اندلاع الاشتباكات وبظل
يعني عدم معرفه ان كان المجتمع الدولي وان
كان اهل البلد مدى طول امد هذا النزاع ومن
هنا طبعا
تمت عمليه الاجلاء هذه
لمحافظه على حياه
وصحه المواطنين
استنفار دبلوماسي في شتى الدول الاثر
اشتباكات السودان عمليه اجلاء الرعايه على
قدم وساق
الولايات المتحده اجلت 100 شخص بثلاث
مروحيات حلقت من جيبوتي مرورا باثيوبيا
وصولا الى السودان مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
والامنيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
قال ان اكثر من الف رعايانا غاده السودان
فرنسا اجلت ما يقارب
538 فردا بينهم اوروبيون وافارقه اما
ايطاليا فاغلقت سفارتها في الخرطوم وطلبت
من 200 شخص ترك الاراضي السودانيه في حين
تنتظر المانيا وصول طائره رابعه للاجلاء
مع ايصال 500 شخص الى بر الامان واجلت
طائره اسبانيه 100 شخص بينهم 30 اسبانيا
وسبعون من اوروبا وامريكا اللاتينيه
وايرلندا بواقع 150 شخصا كما تم اجلاء نحو
25 نمساويا
وتسعه رومانيين وخمسه مجريين وواحد وعشرين
بلغاريا بمساعده دول اخرى
مشاهدينا لنقل الصوره من عمان ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عماد العضايله عماد كيف هي
صوره من هناك
ويعني هل هناك حديث عن العدد كل الصوره من
ارض المطار معك تفضل
نعم كما شاهدتي منذ ان وصلت هذه الطائره
الخامسه الى مطار مارك في العاصمه مطار
ماركا العسكري في العاصمه عمان نزلت
وعلامتها تسعين شخصا تم انزاله وتمت
الاجراءات لمن يريد كما تشاهدين الان هناك
سيده تحتاج لنقلها بسياره الاسعاف تم
تامين يقوموا بنقلها الى الى المستشفى هذه
الطائره كما تحدثنا هي الطائره الخامسه
للطائرات الاجلاء نحاول الان اخذ معالي
وزير الخارجيه للحديث عن الطائرات معالي
الوزير هو نعم
لو سمحت يعني
كما تحدثنا ان هذه الطائره هي الطائره
الخامسه لاجلاء الاردنيين تم اجلاء 343
مواطن اردني بالاضافه الى بعض الرعايه من
الاجانب من الدول العربيه والدول الاجنبيه
ايضا تم نقلهم وتمت الاجراءات الرسميه
بادخالهم الى الاراضي الاردنيه ومن ثم الى
الاراضي الى اراضيهم وبلدانهم الان هناك
تصريح صحفي بالله شوي شوي يا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الان
بوصول هذه الطائره والطائره اللاحقه بعد
ساعات من الان نكون الحمد لله استكملنا
الجزء الاكبر من اجلاء معظم مواطنينا من
السودان في اكبر عمليه اخلاء صراحه نقوم
فيها توجيهات جلال سيدنا ربنا يحمينا
للبدايه كانت ان نكرس كل امكاناتنا من اجل
اخلاء كل مواطن اردني وضمان وصوله وصولها
الى ارض الوطن امين سالمين غانمين الحمد
لله
من يومين من اجلنا حوالي مايزينا 340
مواطن اضافه الى مواطنين من جنسيات اخرى
اليوم حوالي 90
شخص كان على هذه الطائره وايضا الطائره
اللاحقه
تقل مواطنين اردنيين ومواطنين غير اردنيين
من اجل ايصالهم الى الى بلدهم ان شاء الله
في رحله قادمه الان كما قلت اليوم ان شاء
الله نكون استكملنا اخلاء العدد الاكبر من
الاردنيين كل من تواصل مع المعانى وكل من
تواصلنا معه
واراد ان نقوم باخلاقه الحمد لله تم
اخلاقه طبعا بتنسيق وجهود كبيره من نشامى
الجيش العربي سلاح الجو الملكي من كل
مؤسسات الدوله الاردنيه احنا كما تعرفون
كنا شكلنا خليه ازمه من البدايه منذ ما
قبل حتى اندلاء العمليات العسكريه نصحنا
مواطنين بالمغادره بعد الاحداث المؤسفه في
السودان التي نامل ان تنتهي كان هنالك
خليه ازمه على مستوى الوطن توجيهات جلاله
الملك حفظه الله كانت ان نكرز كل
الامكانيات لاجلال ليس فقط المواطنين
الاردنيين ولكن ايضا كل من يحتاج الى عون
ومساعده
والان العدد الاكبر تم اجلائه كل من تواصل
مع الخارجيه واراد ان يتم اخلاقه وتم
اخلاقه السفاره
وباقيه في السودان الى حين اخلاء اخر
مواطن اردني اود ان اؤكد مره اخرى بان هذه
عمليه كبيره كل الدول تتعاون مع بعضها
البعض هنالك مواطنون اردنيون اجليناهم من
الخرطوم على متن طائرات المانيه وهنالك
مواطنون المان وهولنديون
وايضا اجليناهم عبر الطائرات سلاح الجو
الملكي هذه الطائره والطائره اللاحقه
اليوم ستحمل جنسيات عربيه ايضا ما اود ان
اقول اننا نحن في مواجهه اعلى انسانيه
بالنسبه لمواطنين نؤكد بان كل الامكانات
الدوله مكرسه بتوجيهات من جلاله الملك
لاجلائهم واخلاقهم وصولهم سالمين الى
ولدهم ومواطنون الدول الاخرى كل ما نستطيع
ان نقدمه من مساعده نقدمها بكل ما في كل
الامكانيات
في دعم الدول الصديقه والشقيقه الكثير من
الدول جعلت من الاردن قاعده لانطلاق
طائراتها لاخلاق مواطنيها نتعاون بالمطلق
معهم كما قلت هنالك عمليات كبيره المانيا
هولندا دول اخرى كل الدول تتعاون مع بعضها
البعض نحن الان في مواجهه حاله صعبه كل
الدول الشقيقه والصديقه تتعاون تنسق
تتبادل المعلومات وهذا الحد هذا هو
المطلوب في مثل هذه الحاله ما يهمنا هو ان
اخلاء كل المواطنين وايضا نامل ان يتوصل
اخواننا السودانيون الى حل هذه الازمه وقف
لعمليه اطلاق النار حفاظا على السودان
وحفاظا على المواطن السوداني
نحن نقوم الان اولوياتنا الان بان اخلاء
المواطنين
وكما قلت الكل يريد بهذه الازمه ان تنتهي
وتمت جهود يقوم بها الجميع شقائنا في
الدول العربيه في المجتمع الدولي هذه ازمه
لن تنتج الا المزيد من المعاناه للشعب
السوداني ونامل ان يتوصل الاخوه
السودانيون الى حل ينهي هذه الازمه ويوقف
اطلاق النار
ويحمي السودان من تبعات
المزيد من الاقتتال
جمعيه الخاصه قالت ان الاوضاع الامنيه
تقول ذلك عندما تسمح الظروف الاردن لم ولن
يقصر توجيهات جلاله الملك دائما ان كنا مد
يد العون الى كل من يحتاجه اذا كان هنالك
حاجه لمساعدات انسانيه والظروف تسمح بذلك
فالاردن كالعاده سيكون في مقدما في مقدما
يقدم المساعدات
استقرار السودان وامن السودان مسؤوليه على
الجميع نامل ان يتمكنوا من الوصول الى وقت
لاطلاق النار اذا مشاهدينا استمعنا الى
تصريح وزير الخارجيه الاردني ايمن الصفدي
لدى استقبال الوافدين الى مطار الى المطار
في عمان بعدما تم اجلاءهم من الخرطوم شكرا
لعماد العضايله مدير مكتب العربيه في
الاردن على هذه الرسائل وعلى نقل الصوره
من هناك مشاهدينا اظهرت مقاطع فيديو
استقبال مستشفيات في الخرطومه المزيد من
المصابين خلال الاشتباكات بين كل من قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني فيما تواصل
الفرق الطبيه العمل على المستشفيات
والمراكز الطبيه منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات
دون توقف فلنتابع الصور الساعه
[موسيقى]
نفس الاسطاف الموجود من اول يوم
13 الموجود اليوم 11 مستشفى
المصابين يتوافدون الينا من منطقه كافوري
الاسطاف مع زعله هو نفس الافطار نفس
الاسطاف 25 ابريل
[موسيقى]
من جههها دانا الخارجيه السودانيه ما
وصفته باستمرار نهج قوات الدعم السريع
باستهداف السفراء والديبلوماسيين ومقار
البعثات الدبلوماسيه ووصف بيان الخارجيه
السودانيه قوات الدعم السريع بانها
ميليشيا ارهابيه بات الضالعه في ترويع
المواطنين وقتل واستهداف المدنيين البيان
حذر من استغلال الدعم السريع للهدنه في
نشر قواته وارتكاب مزيد من الانتهاكات بحق
المدنيين الخارجيه السودانيه اكدت التزام
الجيش بالهدنه حرصا على حمايه المدنيين
واحترام القانون الدولي
هذا وقررت حكومه شمال كردفان وسط السودان
فرض حظر تجوال ليلي بالولايه ابتداء من
الساعه العاشره مساء وحتى الخامسه صباحا
بتوقيت المحلي ودعا والي الولايه فضل الله
توم الى تضافر الجهود والعمل من اجل تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار والسلم المجتمعي وخلال
الاجتماع انضم لجنه امن الولايه واعضاء
حكومتها وجه المجتمعون بتقديم الدعم
والاسناد اللازم للجيش
معنا مشاهدينا من الخرطوم الصحافه خالد
الفك سابدا معك خالد بموضوع الاجلاء بما
اننا نتحدث الان وننقل الصور لعمليات
الاجلاء الى متى ستستمر وهل من يعني من
اعداد كبيره نتحدث سيتم اجلاء بالساعات
والايام المقبله
التواصل كل السفاره تحاول ان اجدارها او
اجلاء كل من يتصل بها كما قال وزيره
خارجيه للاردني قبل قليل بان كل من تواصل
مع السفاره الاردنيه وتاكدت من اجراءاته
من مواطنين الدول العربيه او بعض الدول
التي هي لجات الى السفاره اعتقد ان
المعبرين الرئيسيين الان هم من البورسودان
حيث انه بالطريقه البري من الخرطوم الى
بورسودان النحوي 1200 كيلو ثم من هناك الى
ميناء جده السعودي فاذا هذا خط اولا ثم
ايضا هناك المعبر الاخر عبر الحدود مع مصر
نظر ارجين وهناك عدد ايضا من الذي تم
وصلوا الى هناك الى معبره لانهم في مدينه
اسوان واعتقد ان يعني كثير من الس
التي قالت انها ما زالت تدرس اجلال
رعاياها ولم تقرر بعد ولكن كل الدول
الاخرى ربما سارعت وذهبت في اتجاه الى
رعاياها وربما هذا مغلق ومحايره سودانيين
في ظل يعني عدم
يعني يعني
او الاقليمي في نقل رعايه مما ينزل
باستمرار مواجهات
طويله الامد استاذ خالد
بموازات عمليات الاجلاء هناك عمليات نزوح
داخلي كبيره ان كان بالداخل السوداني وان
كان نحو الاطراف والدول المحيطه بالسودان
طبعا هناك اجراءات من قبل هذه الدول منها
من يمنع الدخول ومنها من يقوم باجراءات
صارمه عند المعابر ولكن حاله يعني النزوح
الداخليه الكثيفه تعني حاله فوضى داخليه
كثيفه الفوضى الداخلي ه الكثيفه تعني
احتمال انفلات امني الى اي مدى تتخوفون
على الواقع الامني اكثر
[موسيقى]
48 ساعه كانت هناك حركه نسبيه وهدوء نسبي
وعادت يعني كثير من الحياه الى طبيعتها
سواء كان فيهم درمان او في جنوب او حتى في
مناطق في بحري ولكن ما زال هناك القلق
يعني
الخشيه من
ماذا ستبدي بعد الهدنه هل ستكون هناك هدنه
اطول هل ستكون هناك اجراء بمشروع وقف
عدائيات والذهاب الى اتفاق قم الى ان
المواجهات ستستمرها ستستمر بقوه حيث انه
اليوم شاهدنا انه رقم اعلان الهدنه الا
انه شهدنا بعد الخروقات من الطرفين وكله
طرف من الاخر يعني يتهم
الاخر بانه الذي غادر بخرق الهدنه وربما
يعني اكثر من فيديو شهدناه لعمليات هنا
وهناك تشير الى انه كل طرف يحاول ان يثبت
ان الطرف الاخر هو الذي بادر
بخرقه هذه الهدنه اذا كل هذا كل هذا يجعل
هناك حقيقيه للمواطنين
على الوضع الانساني بالوضع الانساني قبل
هذه المعارك وقبل هذه الاشتباكات كان
الناس ينزحون من الاطراف نحو العاصمه بسبب
ما يسمونه بحاله اللا اللادا الاجتماعيه
الموجوده بين المركز والاطراف اليوم نحن
نشهد العكس مما يعنيه مزيد من الفقر مزيد
من الجوع ماذا يعني ذلك على المواطنين
والواقع المجتمعي السوداني
نعم نعم انا اعتقد اعتقد انه الان تحدثيه
تماما من العاصمه والمركز الى الهامش او
الاطراف حيث ان سكان العام في السابق
كانوا يقولون ان المركز هم يسيرون بالسلطه
بالحياه الكريمه بالخدمات الاساسيه
والرئيسيه ولكن اليوم ينعكس الحال تماما
كل الدول التي لا ليس فيها تنميه يعني
متكامله وشامله
نعم نعم فبالتالي هي الان الوضع في
الخرطوم بسبب هذه الاشتباكات وتمددها داخل
الاحياء بجانب ايضا استخدام الاسلحه
الصغيره داخل الاحياء وسقوط عدد من
الدهانات والاسلحه الصغيره من مقله ضحيه
مدنيه هذا كله سبب سعره ومخالف حقيقيه
للمواطن فهو الان يفضل الذهاب بعيدا يعني
نحن شهدنا الان ان هناك اسر فضلت الذهاب
الى اثيوبيا واسر اخرى ربما يعني قبل قليل
مراسل العربيه في القاهره كان في معبر
ارجين ينقل توافد وتدفق السودانيين الى
هناك بعضهم يقول انه يعني اتى دون ان ياخذ
اي شيء فقط بملابسه مما يدل على ان البعض
فضل ان يترك كل ما لديه وان ينجوا بحياته
من هذه الحرب اللعينه فاذا الان هناك
اجراءات عكسيه الى الرزق او حتى هجرات الى
الدول الخارج الدوله السوداني عن فتح
الحدود واستقبال اللاجئين والناجحين من
السودانيين وايضا نطري قال ان الحدود
صالحه هناك تجديد واشتراطات خاصه هناك
مخاوف من عوده بعد المصريين الاسلاميين
الذين هربوا بعض العام 2013 وربما يتقون
مجددا مخاوف امنيه ومخاوف من الارهاب من
العوده الى السودان ومن استغلال الارضيه
الخاصه الموجوده هناك شكرا لك الصحافه
خالد الفكه حدثتنا من الخرطوم
وعلى الحدود السودانيه المصريه تستمر
عمليات الاجلاء للالاف من المصريين
والسودانيين عبر معبر ارقين البري حيث
افادت وسائل الاعلام المصريه عن وصول ما
يقارب 5000 شخص بين مصريين وسودانيين
وجنسيات اخرى عبر المعبر
طويله جدا هاي الرحله كانت
كلها مخاطر وكده
وضارب شديد حاصل هناك
وكده
اعرب رئيس مجموعه البنك الدولي عن شكره
للعاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز على اسهام المملكه ومساعدتها في
اجلاء منسوبي البنك من السودان الى
المملكه وسمنا في خطاب بعثه للملك سلمان
كما عبر عن شكره لسفاره المملكه لدى
جمهوريه السودان ومنسوبيها على الرعايه
والاهتمام لمنسوبي البنك وعائلاتهم الذي
كان له الاثر الكبير في ظل هذه الازمه
قالت وصلت الخارجيه الالمانيه انها لا
تخطط للمزيد من رحلات الاجلاء الالمانيه
من السودان مشيره الى ان اخر رحله اجلاء
من السودان الى الاردن ستنطلق مساء اليوم
واوضحت الخارجيه لالمانيا ان دولا شريكه
ستتولى اجزاء المواطنين الالمان المتبقين
في السودان خلال الايام المقبله
اعلنت هيئه اركان الجيوش الفرنسيه عن
انهائها عمليات الاجلاء نحو جيبوتي وانها
ابقت على فرقاتها في بورتسودان لمساعده
الامم المتحده على عمليات الاجلاء نحو جده
كما اكدت وزاراتها الخارجيه والدفاع
الفرنسيه في بيان مشترك ان عدد الجنسيات
التي استفادت من عمليات الاجلاء الفرنسيه
ارتفع الى 41 جنسيه واشار البيان ايضا الى
ان عمليات الاجلاء حصلت من نقاط التجمع في
الخرطوم نحو قاعده وادي سيدنا ومن القاعده
جوا الى
من لندن مشاهدينا تنضم الينا الصحفيه
والاعلاميه السودانيه الدكتوره رؤى عربي
دكتوره رؤى سابدا من السؤال البديهي الذي
يعني نطرحه في البدايه عمليات الاجلاء
عمليات الاجلاء مع استمرار الهدنه
المتقطعه هل سيحترمها الاطراف بالساعات
المقبله بظل الطلب الامريكي منهم بتمديد
هذه الهدنه لثلاثه ايام ثلاثه ايام مساء
الخير هو تم اختراق هذه الهدنه مرارا خلال
اليوم للاسف الشديد ما في التزام من
الطرفين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي البيانات
هم الاثنين يتراشقوا الاتهامات الوضع
الامني غير مستقر يعني سيء للغايه الكثير
من الاحداث بتاعه النهب في الطريقه السفر
نفسه هو طريق غير امن
للمواطنين او غير المواطنين حتى الاجانب
اللي بيطلعوا عن طريق الخرطوم سواء الج
حتى المحطات بتاعت البنزين يتم نهبها
يعني
بدانا الاضاءه عليه اليوم وايضا يعني حتى
التقارير والصحف الغربيه بان الطريق طريق
الخروج من الخرطوم الى بورسودان ليس فقط
موضوع القصف والاشتباكات وانما عمليات
النهب والسرقه ما ينظر بانفلات امن كبير
كنا نتحدث عنه للساعات الاولى لهذا الصراع
بظل تشتت السلطه المركزيه ماذا يعني ذلك
على واقع السودانيين حتى بعد عمليات
الاجلاء
المعيشي للسودانيين
بالمطلقه الشعب السوداني هو شعب بيتكيف مع
الظروف السيئه احنا طيله حتى الحكم بتاع
الانقاذ مع العقوبات ومع فرض العقوبات
الناس كان بتحاول تجد حلول بديله لكن
اليوم هو الوضع الانساني كارثي لانه حتى
على مستوى الغذاء احنا عندنا مشكله حتى في
الامن الغذائي في توقف اتحدث عن الدقيق
نعم نحن عندنا مشكله في توفر حتى الغذاء
والادويه
المنقذه للحياه يعني حتى الناس اللي عندهم
سكري ضغط الامراض المزمنه هم الان ما
متوفر لهم
العلاجقه شغالين بالعون الذاتي السوداني
شغالين بجمع الحاويات اللي عنده علاج
كفايه ثلاثه اسابيع بيقوم يدي معه شخص اخر
مثلا يقاعد ولا اسبوع او كذا ينتظر ناس من
بره مع قفل الطيارات بقى حتى ما قادرين
انه نساعد اهلنا في السودان ندخل لهم
ادويه لكن الوضع يعني حتى لا يتحمل لكل
السودانيين الموجودين لذلك الناس اختار
تهرب من الواقع ده الهروب ايضا يعني هو
محفوظ بالمخاطر الهروب نحو دول الجوار
يعني يا اما
سيقتنون بمخيمات سيتم انشاء عبر الحدود
بسبب المخاوف الموجوده لدى هذه الدول
واصلا يعني سابدا مثلا من مصر مصر اساسا
تستضيف جاليه كبيره من السودانيين
وبالتالي لن تستقبل اعداد كثيره اليوم
تشاد لديها ايضا مخاوف امنيه هناك من
محاولات انقلاب وغيره من الدول على الحدود
كل هذا كيف سيضيق الخناق عليهم
نعم قبل ان اخذ الاجابه لو سمحتي لرؤى
مشاهدينا هناك سانقل لكم هذه الصور الخاصه
للعربيه التي تظهر اغلاق كامل للمحال
التجاريه في حي الدوحه وحي المنصوره في ام
درمان اذا فلنتابع صوت الطبيعي لهذه الصور
واعود
اذا مشاهدينا تابعت واياكم هذه الصور
للاغلاق التام للمحال بعدد من المناطق في
العاصمه السودانيه اذا هذا ما كنا نتحدث
عنه رؤى بسبب يعني الاشتباكات وبسبب ايضا
عمليات النهب والانفلات الامني فضل اصحاب
هذه المحال بالاغلاق التام بالعوده للسؤال
الذي كنت قد سالته عن الواقع الصعب
لهروب السودانيين من الجحيم الذي يمكن
وصفه الان الموجود في الداخل
رؤى هل تسمعينني
اسمعك انا ما عارفه اذا صوتي واضح نعم
تفضلي
حتى دار الشير لحكايه ارتفاع الاسعار
التذكره الواحده كانت لمصر كانت بتكلف
يعني ما اعرف كم مبلغ لكن اليوم حصلت 200
الف وحصلت 300 من عشرين الف سعر الباص حتى
الناس ما كلها عندها القدره الماليه انها
تسافر خارج السودان حتى حتى قبل هذه
الازمه ازدادت اسعار التذاكر كما اذكر نعم
غير كده حتى اسعار البنزين اسعار التوصيل
كل الحاجات تضخمت الناس ما عندها استطاعه
معظمه انها تعمل الاجراء بتاعتنا تسافر
بيفتكروا حتى الخيار الاكثر امنا انه لو
في ناس من برا الخرطوم اصولهم برجعوا
للمناطق اليوم منها او حتى اذا ناس مثلا
من اهلهم او من الاقارب في مدن كامله يعني
رحبت بالزوار من داخل السودان رجعنا
للجدليه بتاعه المركز والهامش انه من
الاساس احنا في السودان ما مهتمين
بالاقاليب
المتوازنه يعني هذه هذه عله ليس فقط
السودان معظم الدول في المنطقه الماء لا
متوازن بين الدول وتهميش للاطراف على حساب
المركز شكرا لك يا الدكتوره رؤى عربي
الصحفيه والاعلاميه السودانيه على يعني
هذه المداخله من لندن
تعاني مشاهدينا مشارح الخرطوم من ضعف
الساعه الاستيعابيه بعدما ظلت الاف
الجثامين مكدسه فيها لاكثر من ثلاثه اعوام
كما وتهدد مخلفات الحرب من اكوام قمامه
متفشله في الشوارع من ازمتين صحيه وباي قد
تتفشى اذا ما عالجت الدوله جمله ازماتها
عاجله
ملقون على جنبات الشوارع السودان منكبون
على ظهورهم او بطونهم لا فرق
هذا احد تقاطعات حي الحلفايه يلفظ جثثا
مرميه على الاطراف
لايام وما زالت اجسادهم تربك الطرقات
يمشون بجانبها متجاهلين ان انفاسهم انقطعت
وبل من القصف يعرقل سبل نقل رفاتهم فالحي
منهم لا يجرؤ على الذهاب بجثامينهم الى
المشرحه لتكدوسها وايضا خشيه ان ترديه
رصاصه ظلت طريقها اليه فلا هدنه تفي
بالحياه
[موسيقى]
من هنا تنبعث رائحه موت اخر تفوح منه ازمه
صحيه وبيئيه ففي مستشفى الساحه مثلا يتجمع
الجرح من قوه الدعم السريع لكن الكادر
الطبي يعجز عن معالجه الاعداد المتزايده
من الاصابات استمرار نزف احدهم يشي بزياده
عدد القتلى وتضاف اليه عباره كارثيه لا
متسعه لمزيد من الجثث في مشارح الخرطوم
التي تكابد اعدادهم لثلاث سنوات
فمنها جثث تعفنت واخرى تحللت اما عن
رائحتها فحدث ولا حرج
مخلفات الحرب تهدد السودان وتضعه في
تحديات معقده فهناك نفايات بالاكوام
تتكاثر فيها فرص انتشار الامراض المعديه
والجرثوميه لتكاثر الحشرات والذباب حولها
وانبعاث الروائح الكريهه هي المصائب هكذا
لا تاتي فرادى على السودان حرب دروس محمله
بازمتين صحيه وبيئيه اسراء الصغير العربيه
نشد عدد من المواطنين في السودان عبر
كاميرا العربيه جميع الاطراف السودان لوقف
القتال وتامين حاجيات المواطنين وتامين
المحلات التجاريه التي تعرضت للنهب والسلب
خلال الاشتباكات لا للسرغه نحن ما حراميه
نحن سودانيين
يدك على حق غيرك بانه الشعب السوداني تعب
لانه حاصل غلاء في الوطن السودان في غلاء
شديد لا في مويه لا في كهرباء الناس متجهه
لبخاع السودان نسبه لضيق المعيشه في البلد
وعدم توفر الامان
في الشارع لو نزلت الشرطه امنت المواطنين
نزلتو البنزين نزلته كل الناس حترتاح
العنصريه نتكلم عن الجنسيه السودانيه وفقط
ونتكلم عن انسان سوداني انسان سوداني
محترم لا يقبل لا يقبل عن يميد يده لحق
غيره نتكلم عن الحوادث السالبه اللي حصلت
في المحنه دي لا لا للحرب
قال مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه ان نقص الامدادات في العاصمه
السودانيه يتفاقم وان اسعار السلع
الاساسيه ترتفع بسرعه كبيره جدا واضافت
الامم المتحده في بيان انه بعد عشره ايام
من القتال اصبح نقص الغذاء والمياه
والادويه والوقود حادا بشده خاصه في
الخرطوم والمناطق المحيطه بها واشار
البيان الى تقارير عن ارتفاع اسعار السلع
الاساسيه موضحا ان اسعار المياه المعبئه
تضاعفت
مواد السودانيين مع وقف النهائي للقتال
يبقى مؤجلا وكافه الرصاصي لا تزال هي
الارجح على الاقل حتى الان المشهد في
العاصمه يبدو مخيفا محل اقفلها اصحابها
بعد نفاذ المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه منها
وتوقف اسواق الجمله عن العمل ومحل البقاله
القليله التي لا تزال تعمل تكاد تخلو من
البضائع والمتوفر منها تفوق اسعاره قدره
المواطن العادي يعني بكل كهربا مويه يمكن
يشد عليه هنا والخبز اهو زي ما انت شايف
اربعين دقيقه بين اربعين الى 60 دقيقه
عشان تقدر اشيل لك
عشر عشرين عيشه
الحمد لله
حامدون وشاكرون رغم قسوه الصراع والاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه يعني
انه
في استغلال يعني حتى لو الباكو بتاع
الدقيقه الليله ب 8000 هيديك له قريبا
والسيارات هذه وكانها بلا نهايه في ام
درمان تصطفوا الى جانب محطات الوقود رغم
يقيني اصحابها بخلو تلك الخزانات من اي
وقود ولو توفرت فالاسعار المطلوبه غير
متوفره
ازمات السودانيين تتضاعف مع الانقطاع
المتكرر لخدمات الانترنت والاتصالات
الهاتفيه فضلا عن شرح السيوله النقديه
واغلاق البنوك لتبقى اصوات الرصاص
المتقطعه في هدنه هشه لتزيد مخاوف
السودانيين من اطاله امد الصراع حنان
المصري العربيه
مشاهدينا للحديث اكثر عن الازمه السودانيه
وعن الواقع على الارض تنضم الينا
بالاستديو مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
لنا اليعقوب لينا سابدا من موضوع الجثث
التي رايناها انت قبل هذه الازمه يعني
بوقت اعدادت تقارير كثيره وتحقيق كبير عن
موضوع الجثث التي اصلا هي مكدسه ما قبل
هذه الازمه اليوم ازمه مياه ازمه كهرباء
ازمات ازمه صحيه وبالتالي تفشي اوبيه
وامراض على مستوى واسع كثيرا لماذا
مساء الخير عليك العيال نعم الان الازمه
ستتكرر ولكن بتفاصيل اخرى الجساميل
المكدسه كانت موزعه على ثلاث مشارح رئيسيه
في
الخرطوم وام درمان الان هذا الامر يتكرر
لكن بصيغه اخرى تكدس هذه الجسامير صحيح ان
اعدادها ليس كبير ولكن وجود هذه الجثانيم
في الشوارع وعدم القدره على الذهاب بها
الى المشارح لتكون بعد ذلك ضمن مجهولي
الهويه اصلا المشاعرها غير مؤهله المشاريع
غير مؤهله والمشارح مكدسه وان تصل هذه
الجسامين الى المستشفيات بصوره متحلله وان
لا يعرف لا يعرف من صاحبها هذا يعني انها
لن تدفن وهذا يعني استمرار لازمه الجثامين
كما ذكرتي انت هناك وضع صحي
كارثيات خارج الخدمه حتى الادويه الاساسيه
غير موجوده يعني هل نتوقع انتشار لامراض
واوئه بالفتره المقبله اذا ما لم تتحرك
المنظمات الدوليه خصوصا ان على مستوى
الرسمي غائبين نهائيا نعم ليال هو الامراض
تحدث عنها الاطباء يعني ربما نحن لسنا
اكثر علما منهم وهم يتحدثون طوال اليوم في
العربيه والحدث عن
الاضرار والاثار المترتبه على وجود هذه
الجثانين في الشوارع هناك جانب انساني
واخلاقي وهناك ايضا جانب صحي وهناك تبعات
اخرى ايضا الرعب الذي يدخل على الاطفال
ويشعر به الاطفال حينما يرون جثث ملقاه
على الشارع عامل نفسه ايضا يعني يؤثر على
نفسيتها هؤلاء لنا يعني من الناحيه الاخرى
ايضا هناك اليوم يعني بالاربع سنوات
الماضيه العمله السودانيه تراجعت حوالي 9
بالمئه اليوم مع هذه الازمه ايضا هناك
تراجع السودانيين ما قبل الازمه كانوا
يعني غير قادرين الا على سد الاحتياجات
الاساسيه مع هذه الازمه كيف سيكون الواقع
على الارض
الواقع على الارض سيء وكثير من الناس الان
يتشائمون به ولكن هناك امل بان تتوقف هذه
الحرب حتى لن اقول يعود الوضع كما هو عليه
بهذه السرعه ولكن على الاقل ان تهدا هذه
الاشتباكات وما يترتب على هذه الاشتباكات
من تدني في جميع الخدمات فضلا عن وجود وهو
العامل الاهم وهو العامل الاكثر تاثيرا
بان
تحدث حالات من القتل جراء هذا القصف وهذه
الاشتباكات ان يكون هناك مرضى ولا اغلى من
الروح ثم بعد ذلك نتيجه هذه الاشتباكات
التي يترتب عليها نقص الكهرباء والمياه
اغلاق للجامعات والمدارس ضعفي الوضع الصحي
انعدام للوقود انعدام في الادويه
والصيدليات عدم القدره على الحركه كل هذا
الامر يزداد سوءا بعد يوم لم تتحرك كما
ذكرت جهات مختصه خاصه اننا لم نرى حتى
الان اي دور فاعل للمنظمات الامميه في هذه
التي انسحبت يعني بهذه الازمه بسبب
الانفلات الامني الهجره من المركز الى
الاطراف الاطراف اصلا تعاني من نقص على
كافه المستويات اليوم نتحدث عن اعداد
كبيره بهجره عكسيه يعني عاده تكون الهجره
بنوع مختلف ايضا ماذا يعني ذلك على هذه
المجتمعات اذا لم يكن هناك تدخل اممي
المجاوره التي بعض الدول لديها
لديها اعتبارات سياسيه امنيه وغيرها
والدول الاوروبيه اصلا هي بدات يعني منذ
فتره طويله اجراءات معقده للمهاجرين
وبالتالي يعني حتى الهروب من الجحيم صعب
اليوم على السودانيين نعم صعب ولكن كما
ذكرت لك كثير من السودانيين لا يرغبون
الان في هذا الخيار معظم السودانيين
المفضلون البقاء والانتظار والانتظار الى
ما يمكن ان تسهري عنه يعني هذه الاشتباكات
هل ستنتهي قريبا هل يمكن ان يعود الوضع
كما هو عليه هل ستتحسن هذه الدوله بعد
انهاء صراع هو الذي ادى الى هذا الامر وهو
امر كان يحدث توتر كبير خلال الفتره
الانتقاليه الى ماذا سينتهي هذا الصراع
ربما كثير من السودانيين الان ينتظرون هذا
الامر قبل اتخاذ قرار يتعلق بالمجاد
المغادره لنا سؤال الاخير لو سمحت كنا
تبعنا سيطره احد طرفي النزاع على مختبر
[__] يعني البيولوجيه وتخوف من المنظمه
الصحه العالميه بامكانيه استخدامها كسلاح
حرب وهي يعني تمت بحروب عده من قبل يعني
بمعرفتك بهؤلاء الموجودين على الارض هل
ممكن الذهاب نحو تهور من هذا النوع لا اظن
لا اظن كل التهور الان الموجود ينصب في
هذه الجرائم التي تحدث
بعض السرقات
ربما حالات يعني
رعبه التي تتابع المواطنين مما
يفعله بعض القوات وتحديدا يعني القوات
التي ترتدي زي الدعم السريع التي في كثير
من الاحيان تواجدت في منطقه وسط الخرطوم
وطلبت الاهالي بالخروج من منازلهم هذا
اقسم ما وصل اليه الحال حتى الان في
السودان لكن ذلك النوع من التشفي او
الانتقام او استخدام اسلحه بيولوجيه لا
نعتقد انه خيار قد يكون مطروحا شكرا لك يا
لينا يعقوب مديره مكتب العربيه على وجودك
معنا
والان مشاهدينا الى موجز لابرز الاخبار
رفض الكرملين
[موسيقى]
رفض الكريم المزاعم التي تشير الى وجود
شبيه بالرئيس الروسي الفلاديمير بوتين
يمثله في المناسبات وانا بوتين يقضي معظم
وقته في الحمايه بمخبئ النووي المتحدث
باسم كريم
وصف هذه المزاعم بالاكاذيب مشددا على ان
بوتين كان ولا يزال نشطا للغايه وبصحه
ممتازه
الامن الروسيه نيكولاي بطرشاف بمحاولات
الولايات المتحده التحضير لحرب بيولوجيه
ضد روسيا ودول اخرى وشدد باتروشاف خلال
الجلسه العامه سنويا للمجلس العلمي في
اطار مجلس الامن ان الابحاث البيولوجيه
الخاصه التي تستخدمها الولايات المتحده في
تطوير برامجها العسكريه تتطلب اهتماما
كبيرا من المجلس وفق قوله
اجرى وزيره الدفاع الروسي سرقه محادثات
رباعيه في موسكو مع نظرائه في ايران
وروسيا وتركيا وقالت وزاره الدفاع التركيه
ان الوزراء ناقشوا خلال الاجتماع تعزيز
الامن في سوريا وتطبيع العلاقات بينها
وبين تركيا في المقابل نقلت صحيفه الوطن
السوريه عن مصدر لم تسميه القول انه لا صح
للبيان الذي بثته وزاره الدفاع التركيه
والذي تحدث عن خطوات ملموسه تتعلق بتطبيع
العلاقات بين تركيا وسوريا
اعلنت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مقتل احد
عناصرها بعد تعرض سياره القتيل لقصف من
طيران مسير تركي في منطقه كوباني شماليه
البلاد بدوره افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان بمقتل شخصين واصابه الثالث بجراح
خطيره جراء استهداف طائره مسيره تركيا
جنوب كوباني والتي تقع ضمن مناطق سيطره
قوات قصد في ريف حلب الشرقي
اعلن الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2024 ليصبح بعمر
ثمانين عاما كاكبر مرشح يخوض حمله جديده
الى البيت الابيض وكتب على تويتر انه
متمسك بالدفاع عن الديمقراطيه مشيرا الى
ان الحريات الشخصيه في الولايات المتحده
تتعرض لهجوم من الجمهوريين المتطرفين بحسب
تعبيره
يواجه الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب محاكمه مدنيه في منهات بتهمه اغتصاب
الكاتبه الصحفيه ايجين كارل قبل نحو 30
عاما ومن المقرر ان تبدا اليوم عمليه
اختيار هيئه القضاه في محكمه نيويورك
الفيدراليه وكانت كارول قد اتهمت ترامب
بالاعتداء عليها في متجر كبير في منهات
اواخر عام
1995 وعمد الى التشهير بها حينما كشفت عن
الواقع لكن الرئيس السابق نفد تهمه واتهم
الصحفيه باختلاق القصه من اجل الشهره
نقلت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه مقتطفات من
خطاب وزير الخارجيه البريطاني يرسم
السياسه الخارجيه للحكومه حيالبكين وسيحد
الخطاب على تفادي سياسه العزل الحياه
للصين وتجنب الحديث عن حرب بارده جديده
وسيدعو ايضا الى انخراط بناء مع بكين يشمل
القضايا الدوليه الرئيسيه كما سيتعهد وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني بتعزيز الامن القومي
في مواجهه تنامي قدرات بكين العسكريه
والتعاون مع الحلفاء
مشاهدينا الى هنا انهي معكم هذه الساعه
الاخباريه لكن تغطيه العربيه مستمره طبعا
للتطورات والاحداث في السودان والان الى
ساعه جديده مع الزميله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات